we've thought we were financially secure
we had plenty of debt but we were always
on time on paying our bills and whatnot
we made everything on credit card
because we were at Sea World and we saw
it there and so we must have been on a
vacation for the weekend so we would
just charge things on credit card I mean
like looks good my idea of if we could
actually afford something to buy
something was whether we could afford
the monthly payments and if we still had
money left over that month clearly we
could afford another $350 payment this
is our dining room table that we
purchased right before Financial Peace
University no interest payments for like
three years it's amazing look at our
credit score we're we have arrived what
you're not gonna get that happen again
like we never made payments late ever
and so that was just a justification
that everything was okay we thought that
was managed Tet that we were doing a
good job
until one day I unexpectedly lost my job
I really thought that we weren't a part
of that high percentage of Americans
that live paycheck to paycheck that
wasn't us until we had the possibility
of one paycheck not coming in anymore
just seeing her you know stressed and
tense I knew that the situation wasn't
good all of a sudden one day this Dave
Ramsey show came on and at first I was
like hi you know I didn't want to listen
to it too much than after a couple days
this guy's making some sense I tried to
pitch it to her to no avail
it's about biblical finance and they're
Scripture I was like whoa because we
weren't saved at the time it was a
Friday when I went online and a next
series of class was gonna start that
following Monday when he told me he
wanted to go to this class and that it
was something we could do together I
found that kind of exciting so I said oh
okay so I'll go
- swelled on the tree right now looking
at the verb I was driving home each day
and listening to the show everybody was
doing these steps they were doing their
debt-free screams
inspiring to hear others you know going
through this process and getting out of
debt
it was unbelievable once budgeting and
seeing how it works and you can see
those levels as they raise we actually
paid off over eighty six hundred dollars
while we were in our nine week class we
cut out everything going to movies going
out anything like that we would budget
ourselves maybe three or four dollars so
we could go to the red box and that
would be our date night because you know
we knew that this is what was important
while we have been going to the church
where FPU was I knew that I had felt
this tug in my heart and I knew that
change was coming I was on my way home
from work that night right after FPU
finished um I was listening to the CD
you're in a car listening to this pull
over the side of the road bow your head
with me right there and I'm just gonna
say a little simple prayer and I want
you to say that with me I said the
prayer that was in that CD and listen to
Dave talk about that and it was in my
car that night that like I first you
know accepted the Lord into my heart and
I knew that Jesus was the son of God
that's not why I was there I was there
to learn financial you know how to do
the debt snowball on how to do the
different things relating to debt I was
not there for any sort of spiritual
growth or gain but through those nine
weeks of you know being in the class
listen to what was being said listen to
Dave everything really clicked and it
made sense I think this is the whole
reason why we ended up going FPU it's an
amazing process to clean up financially
and to become responsible adults and to
not have debt but we know that that's
like that's just such a small piece of a
puzzle now in the lobby of financial
piece Plaza Jason and Sarah are with us
hey guys how are you when we got to do
that scream we had come we thought we
practice for it before we got there but
no we we let it all out
you
with the financial freedom that we
received from FPU we don't have to
stress in you know situations we have an
emergency fund in place now we had a
good solid friendship and relationship
before things are on a whole nother
level now it taught us how to manage
money instead of money managing us all
the time the biggest change that I've
seen in Jason is his involvement he has
turned into the man that I have always
dreamed that will lead our family he's
taking care of our family and the way
that he treats me as his wife I just I
feel so blessed every day that I get to
have him as my husband Wow I don't know
the back story the house is very very
cool I'm proud of you guys you know I
grew up an atheist and just was it I
just wanted to support her and then we
went there like I said we found an
unbelievable pastor totally changed my
views on everything on life is evident
on all my whole life and our whole life
and our trajectory of our life as long
as you said here to the steps you can
achieve the goals that you want to
achieve